London's Heathrow is the busiest airport
in Europe but from today has another
status when it comes to tackling climate
change now carbon neutral it hopes the
airport infrastructure won't be
producing any carbon emissions at all by
the mid 2030s Matt Gorman Heathrow's
director of sustainability says the
airport is the first in the world to
make such a pledge the enemy at the end
of the day is not aviation its carbon
our collective challenge isn't just
Aviation's to get carbon out of the
economy as quickly as possible and we
have to play our role in getting there
so but but still doesn't it feel awkward
that you're making these kind of
laudable emission statements but
actually you're servicing such as the
carbon intensive industry not at all I
think personally I believe that aviation
brings huge benefits economically
socially and culturally Heathrow's
commitments covering missions generated
by its own operations including airport
buildings infrastructure business travel
and its vehicles but they don't include
emissions from its suppliers airport
businesses like shops and restaurants
the possible construction of a third
runway or crucially the flights in spite
of climate concerns record numbers are
expected to take to the skies globally
in 2020 as airports have grown the
objective has been to travel as quickly
and as cheaply as possible but companies
are under pressure to consider the cost
to the environment our initiative is
more broad-based than just net zero we
saw ourselves a goal to become zero net
zero carbon by 2030 aim to be net zero
there's been a flurry of announcements
by big businesses promising to reduce or
eliminate their carbon footprint
the government says Britain will be
carbon neutral by 2050 but hasn't
created any kind of regulatory body to
check the voluntary pledges being made
there's really no rigor as to whether
that you know whether these meet the
test are they going to allow the country
to actually meet its Net Zero target by
2050 polling last year showed the 30
percent of companies don't even have a
plan in spite of promises to reduce air
emissions aviation emissions are
expected to rise dramatically
sustainable air travel from start to
finish is still a long way off Lisa
Holland Sky News